this was a flight into the history books
a journey of peace they say the word
displayed in the three languages of the
brokers of the deal
which allowed it to happen
genuinely it marks a significant shift
in the geopolitics of this region
an israeli airline full of israeli
government officials
off to the arab world and with the
americans taking credit for the whole
thing
i do believe that this is ushering in a
new hopefulness
amongst all people that peace is
possible
and that there's a new chapter that can
be written and i just want to
acknowledge that this has been
president trump's vision for the middle
east from the very beginning
and yet it was an irony that the plane's
journey took it straight over the
missing element in all this
the palestinians
speaking as the plane was flying
overhead the palestinian prime minister
said it has hurt us very much to see an
israeli plane landing in the emirates
it's a clear and blatant violation of
the arab position
regarding the arab israeli conflict
for the very first time in israeli
register in israeli-registered aircraft
saudi arabia they see it as an arab
betrayal compounded by the decision of
the saudi government to allow the plane
into their airspace
another first as it touched down in abu
dhabi the israeli flag was displayed for
the first time in these parts
a signal that the uae is formally
recognizing the jewish state
and ditching the convention that it
would never do so until the formation of
a state of palestine
on the tarmac mr trump's son-in-law was
making the most of the american
president's role in the deal
there is an election to win and he was
blunt in his assessment that it is the
palestinians fault that they are not
there
the very few who have been critical of
this peace agreement
are the ones with a long track record of
failure
and trapping their own people in misery
and poverty
they exploit the vision to maintain
power but their rhetoric has grown tired
and the region is breaking free from
their grip
but that's an assessment which
palestinians here in east jerusalem and
over there behind israel's wall in the
west bank
will find deeply offensive it's true
that as part of the deal the israeli
threat to annex parts of the west bank
has gone away it's also true
that the palestinians flatly refuse to
engage with any part of donald trump's
peace plan but their argument is why
should we the plan doesn't give the
palestinians a capital city
here in east jerusalem and it doesn't
give them as much land as everyone
agreed to
in the oslo accord so many years ago
this may be a real politic approach and
a new alliance against iran
but it threatens to leave the
palestinians behind and they are still
at the heart of the problem and the
solution in this region
a peace flight and a peace deal it may
be but without the palestinians
where can it really lead mark stone sky
news in jerusalem